tasha that turmoil between dr jarrah and
the trustees adding to a long list of
problems that teachers say is really
leading the low morale kate houston in
studio she spoke to a teacher who has
decided to leave the district kate she
joins us now
yes and this low morale also stems from
problems during the pandemic a lack of
resources for educators and major
burnout a teacher i spoke with says it's
piling on and something needs to be done
i'm to the point now where i'm so burned
out that i don't care if i'm here or not
teachers say the problems in ccsd are
coming to a head jamie anderson is
getting ready to leave after six years
of teaching in the district the district
is going to lose a lot of really good
teachers
if they can't figure out
how to fix this because this situation
is absolutely like treacherous at this
point anderson says demands have
increased tremendously leaving teachers
overwhelmed much of this comes from
vacancies stretching teachers between
classrooms a lack of adequate health
insurance teachers having to learn a new
grading policy and a lack of support
anderson says the turmoil between jarrah
and trustees is taking away from
addressing these issues it just seems
like again one thing on top of another
and at this point now i feel like any
district
would be better than being in ccsc i
don't want to leave my career of
teaching but i do want to leave ccsd in
order to keep staff anderson says the
district needs to offer more emotional
support i think that the thing that i've
seen across the board that teachers just
want
is more number one recognition for the
hard work that we're putting in after
everything we've gone through in the
last two years and then number two like
more supports in place
for those teachers
this week board president linda cavazos
told me she wants the discussions
tonight to be civil and she hopes they
can look at this as a learning
experience and find a way to move
forward denise okay